Heidi congratulations on making it to
the final three of Survivor 44. how are
you feeling now that you know everything
is out there the finale's there
everything all the love and everything's
pouring out online how are you feeling
I'm feeling fantastic it's been a
wonderful ride crazy but wonderful so
I'm feeling grateful and super happy
thank you I'm so excited to be here yay
I'm so glad that I get to talk to you
today now I have to talk about that
final immunity challenge the stress my
heart is racing every time they do that
challenge I am just like my heart is
racing so I can't even imagine what you
guys are going through but you know when
you won and you got that immunity
necklace like how were you feeling in
that moment and what was going through
your head
it it's so hard to describe the feeling
at the time because first of all it
happens so quick right and then I was
jumping of excitement I think I was
dancing a little bit of everything the
moment is so epic and for me it was the
first challenge win right so it was like
ah yes I facilitated and I kept thinking
of my girls I have two girls so I kept
thinking of my girls like I hope I make
them proud this is for us so
watching it though last night just like
you said my heart was racing I even know
what's gonna happen but my heart was
racing I'm watching like I'm a fan too
right so it's it's pretty fantastic and
my kids were crying because they had no
idea what was happening I never told
them the outcome so they were crying
when they saw what happened so seeing
them so emotional it was a fabulous
moment for my family and myself so super
super exciting
oh I love hearing that I was going to
ask you how your daughters responded but
what was how was your family's reaction
like your two daughters to the whole
season like are they just so proud of
you
they they are it's so interesting
because oh my God yeah we watched the
show as a family and my kids are 8 and
13. so it's a big range like really
young and a teenager and we still watch
the show as a family and now it's like
you're watching your mother there it's
even more exciting but because they
didn't know the outcome or anything that
was happening she was they were still
excited like when I found the idol my
girls were like hugging me and it was so
fun because they if they were just
excited to see everything that happened
um and they were watching as a fan yeah
it was their mother so it was all
positive a great great positive
experience and I hope that they had a
post I'm sure they are proud and they're
having a they're having a blast too they
think they're part of the family I think
they're part of the family of the
Survivor family so yeah no it's been
everything has been so positive nothing
negative to say oh I love that that's
such a special moment to share with your
family and I'm so glad you got to
experience that now maybe what do they
think about your decision to make fire
against Carson because I know you said
on the show that like at tribal that you
kind of were waiting until that moment
you hadn't made that decision yet but
when did you really was there a moment
at tribal or even before where you were
like okay I'm gonna do this obviously it
paid off but like that's an intense
insane decision to go for after you've
already secured that safety so it's so
interesting because when I win that
challenge and Jeff is putting the
necklace on me and he's saying you just
guarantee the top three that is when it
hit me like I had a planet right like I
yeah you want to be in at the end but
you're also like not trying to set your
mind like oh yeah it's a done deal
because it's not so when he said it it
just hit me like okay unless I make fire
because that means I could still go out
so it just hit me at that moment now
like Fast Forward I really wasn't sure
if I was gonna come through and just do
it because taking the immunity necklace
off is the hardest thing to do in this
game because it's like taking your city
out so I really really didn't know that
Tribal Council that I was gonna do it so
for me to actually do it and pull
through and actually make it that fast
mind-blowing I'm proud I'm proud of that
moment that's such a big moment for me
and I'm so happy actually he came all
together so yeah I'm proud of that
moment that's amazing and you should be
I mean the fastest fire making in
Survivor history like although you
didn't win the million dollars I feel
like you crossed so many things off of
your Survivor bucket list you know you
made the fire you found the idol like
how does it feel to have those things
crossed off your list listen I've been
talking about this and I so I talked
about this since the the show ended last
night because you do have bucket lists
okay first of all I got on Survivor
because it was a bucket list item for me
like I I love this show so much let me
try it even though it sounds so insane
that I'm gonna get on right I'm gonna
send a video and check I'm done so the
whole thing for me started as a bucket
list item even sending my video so now
in the Island right it's like I found an
idol I found an advantage I you know I
made fire on the first day and then at
the end I didn't have the winning a
challenge but I got it too making fire
breaking record yeah the only one I
didn't check was the sole survivor but
I'm content because my resume was very
good on my bucket list I didn't know my
experience is nothing but positive oh
that's amazing to hear now were you
surprised with how the votes played out
between you and jam Jam like Danny voted
for you
um he shared why but were you
anticipating anyone else to kind of vote
your way or were you not surprised
um of course surprise because I'm
hopeful that I gave them enough to win
the game right so yeah like surprised
because I was hopeful not surprised
because like jam is a fantastic Jam time
is a fantastic winner so I would never
take that away for him from from him uh
but yeah I was definitely I was hoping
to get the numbers it's a numbers game I
am I'm an engineer so I'm a numbers
person person you better believe it
um yeah it didn't go my way but but that
is okay if I was gonna lose to anyone
let it be jam Jam because he's an
amazing person so no regrets behind the
outcome uh we all like you know us we
are so grateful for the opportunity and
we're friends now outside the game so no
hard feelings against the jury they they
did what they thought it was best at the
time and I respect that
I love that and I love how this season
was so positive and everyone was it felt
like a family and I feel like that's
what you just said like you guys are all
still friends Jam Jam couldn't I just
spoke to him and he couldn't say
anything but positive things about you
and Carolyn but um I also want to talk
to you about your uh one of your
speeches during the final Tribal Council
you know you're talking about you know
representing Puerto Ricans and also
representing women in science in
powerful jobs and Powerful positions
like you were a total badass the entire
season and that speech really was
powerful to hear
um what does it mean to you to be able
to represent Puerto Rico and also
represent strong powerful women
thank you for the question so in fact
this is my why the reason why I talked
about the bucket list item yes because I
love the show and I I always thought it
would be a dream come true to make it
which is it is it's a dream come true
but my true why for being on TV or even
doing this whole ride is I there's not a
whole lot of Heidi's on TV there's not a
whole lot of me people that look
different and so different right
um and yet I to push it even further
like females in stem and Engineering
there's not many of us there's not a
whole lot of us so if I could Empower or
like make someone out there think or say
hey if she can do it I can too that's
that's just gonna fill me up because
that's exactly why I'm here
um I'm at a stage of my life where I I
know that I could help and Empower other
people to follow similar steps and hey
grow even bigger than me right this guy
is the limit so I also have two young
girls so I want my girls to be empowered
to do whatever it is they want in their
future so I now looking forward the
things the way they talk about me it's
like the greatest gift because they know
I was chasing a dream so I hope they
chase their dreams whenever they come to
that age where they have to chase their
dreams so yeah sky's the limit so this
is what it's all about for me so if I
can Inspire one person out there I did
my job and I hope I did oh you
definitely did like the outpouring of
Love online is insane and that's such a
beautiful way to put it as well for your
family and your daughters I absolutely
love that now lastly I want to ask you
you know 26 days on the island other
than you know
um empowering people and women and
generations what would you say for
yourself was like the biggest lesson you
learned or your biggest takeaway from
your time in the game
it's an easy answer because I've thought
about this so much especially when I'm
flying back home after the whole
experience he I think as human beings we
don't need a whole lot there clearly we
survive with not a whole lot of food no
technology no
um nothing about like sleeping
accommodations none of that none of that
Comfort but what really matters is the
people the people that you love the
people that they love you so yes I think
what I got the most out of the
experience is like make sure I'm present
and I'm loving the people and giving the
people the love back because people are
giving me love and I wanna including the
fans right I want to make sure I give
them love back because that's what this
is all about I don't care about the
phones and the computers and the
material things so if anything I got out
of that is just being grateful for the
people and the love and just making sure
I'm pressing and I give them the love
back for sure
oh that's amazing that's a great way to
just kind of sum up your entire journey
and you know you should be so proud of
yourself it was a pleasure watching you
on Survivor this season and thank you so
much for talking with me today and
congratulations again for all of your
bucket list achievements
um thank you so much it's so nice to
meet you love you love you back